Speaker 2: All right. So as we continue to in
some sense, wait to see what ultimately happens
with criminal charges against the failed former
president Donald Trump, he has returned to his
Mar a Lago home for the first time since the now
infamous search warrant that was served for the
raid, as many call it, in Mar a Lago. And Donald
Trump is absolutely furious. He's raging that the
FBI allegedly didn't take their shoes off when
they went into his house and all sorts of other
crazy things. There's just a lot going on. And
some of the cultists were up all night waiting
to welcome Donald Trump. Trump at Mar a Lago.
So let's go through all of it. Business Insider
reports Donald Trump is back at Mar a Lago and
raging about FBI agents not taking off their
shoes while searching his bedroom. Donald
Trump published a message to truth social,
also known as Truth Essential, where he said,
quote, I arrived in Florida last night and
had a long and detailed chance to check out
the scene of yet another government crime,
the FBI's raid and break in of my home, Mar a
Lago. Remember, it was not a crime and it was
not a break in. The FBI showed up with a search
warrant. FBI director signed off on it. Attorney
general signed off on it. A judge signed off on
it. Perfectly legal. Trump going on to say I guess
they don't think there is a Fourth Amendment
anymore and to them there isn't. Of course,
there is no Fourth Amendment violation because
of the things I just mentioned. Trump continuing.
In any event, after what they have done, the
place will never be the same. It was, quote,
ransacked. Now, why does Trump put ransacked in
quotes? Does he mean it wasn't really ransacked?
Because when you put it in quotes, it almost
suggests he doesn't think it was ransacked
anyway and in far different condition than the
way I left it. Many agents. And they didn't even
take off their shoes in my bedroom. Nice. Nice.
Now, to give you a sense of the level of cultish
ness that's going on here. There were people
waiting for Trump's arrival in the middle of
the night lining the street. Check this out.
Speaker 3: I'm coming back to his Florida home
Sunday night. Dozens of supporters waiting along
the bridge on Southern Boulevard, waving their
flags, cheering as he drove through. Yeah.
Speaker 2: This is a cult. This is a cop.
And it's not even like I'm necessarily
passing a value judgment. I mean,
I do in other segments, obviously, I think it's
an absurd cult based on lies and confusion, but.
It's a cult. And if you we've spoken to cult
experts and that is indeed what it is. There's
another video. This one is from. This one was from
yesterday afternoon, which was hours before Trump
even got back. Real America's Voice. American
Sunrise was there. This was at 8 a.m.. And you
see all these people holding crosses, some guy
dressed as Trump. American flags. Trump flags,
other paraphernalia. A sign that said Trump
won honk for Trump. Just all sorts of different
characters because this, you know, they're
waiting to welcome a potential criminal.
That's what they're doing here. Now, my prediction
is. That with Donald Trump back at Mar a Lago.
And understand, there's two parts to this. One,
Trump's back at Mar a Lago, which he considers
the scene of the crime or whatever. I think it'll
be it'll trigger him more than being in New York,
being back there. And that will probably lead to
a particularly unhinged Trump. But also Mar a Lago
has become a sort of like it's almost like the
wedding at the beginning of The Godfather where
all of the acolytes and brown noser and suck ups
are making their pilgrimages, so to speak. And
that's what they do at Mar a Lago. Trump hosts
people, everything, everybody from, you know,
Kyle Rittenhouse to other right wing heroes.
Yeah, I know. And so it's likely, I would say,
that Trump's visitors are going to fire him up
and give him ideas. He'll probably be meeting
with lawyers. And so I expect it's going to be a
really, really crazy week. One other little note
on what's been going on with Trump lately. There
has been a preview released by Newsmax of what
they're calling a special. And this is a special
in which right wing actor Jon Voight, who's the
father of actress Angelina Jolie, Jon Voight,
who really has not seemed with it for a while in
terms of his connection to reality. He actually
wept during the interview, or maybe wept is too
much. He cried. So this is something else we're
going to be watching out for very, very closely.
Speaker 3: And she came in and you said, I
hear you have a little bit of a difficult.
And she said, well, I have some cancer issues and.
Speaker 1:
So I'm getting emotional. This is from the.
You keep saying the champ. You can watch
the champ. I cry. Well, I can't. I can't
just go through this story without crying.
Speaker 2: And you said I'll take care
of you. Yeah. So a visibly emotional
Jon Voight overcome with how good of a
person and genuine and caring and all of
these other things that we have no evidence
for Donald Trump is. So that's the latest
there. And we'll keep an eye on Mar-A-Lago
this week. Could be could be quite a week